This episode is sponsored by
Fabulous, an app that helps you
start building your ideal daily routine.
The first 100 people who click on the
link in the description will get
25% off a Fabulous subscription.
The world is simply too vast for any organism
to find its way alone. There are too many turns,
too many challenges...inevitably, we all reach
points where we need just a little bit of help.
And the microcosmos is no exception. The world’s
earliest relationship builders were microbes,
who—through some combination of chance
and biology—found ways to use each other.
The word for this, of course, is symbiosis,
and it is not restricted to microbes. You
can watch many a nature documentary and
find many examples of birds or fishes or
large mammals that form symbiotic relationships.
Perhaps one feeds on the pests living on another,
and the other provides shelter.
But there are many symbiotic relationships
that we can see under the microscope as well.
One of the most famous examples of symbiosis
is that of Paramecium bursaria. The Paramecium
bursaria looks like an ellipse with hairs
poking out of it, which means that for the most
part, it looks just like any other paramecium.
But there’s one big distinction: the Paramecium
bursaria is green. And it’s green thanks to a
whole host of algae called Chlorella that have
taken up residence inside its body because,
well, generations ago, many generations ago,
a Paramecium ate some algae. But instead of
digesting the algae, the Paramecium just didn’t.
And instead, it started to consume the products
of the Chlorella’s synthesis and then it
passed that algae on to the next generation.
And in return, the Chlorella gets to use
the paramecium—its former predator—as
a form of protection and transportation.
But scientists have separated the bursaria from
it’s algal symbionts and, it turns out, both of
them can survive on their own. Because each of the
members of the relationship benefits, it’s called
mutualism, but because it is optional it’s called
“facultative.” So the paramecium bursaria and its
chlorella are an example of facultative mutualism.
So, this all seems pretty
simple and straightforward.
Symbiosis is a biological exchange of
goods and/or services, an uncomplicated
means of partnering up to help survive.
But relationships are always easier in theory. In
practice, they can be much more complicated
and difficult to understand. And for us,
as outsiders, it takes considerable work
to decipher just what kind of relationship
microbes are forming with each other.
James, our master of microscopes, found
this ciliate in some mud. And if you’re wondering
what those fuzzy rod shapes are inside of it,
those are prokaryotes stuffing up the ciliate.
But besides knowing that those are prokaryotes
in there, we can’t really tell much about what
they’re doing or what their relationship is with
their ciliate host. Do those prokaryotes help the
ciliate survive in the low-oxygen environment of
mud? Are they why we can’t see any food vacuoles
in the ciliate? Are they even helping each other
at all or are they parasitizing each other?
Trying to decipher all of that just by looking at
it, would be like trying to describe the complex
dynamics of a family just by looking at their
portrait. So to dive deeper into what’s going on,
James has isolated and frozen some of these cells
in tiny tubes, storing them for a future day
when he’ll be able to study them more closely.
Now, one of the disorienting aspects
of symbiosis at the microbial level
is that eukaryotic organisms are full of
parts that look a bit like other organisms.
And that is not a coincidence. In some cases,
things like chloroplasts and mitochondria are
the product of endosymbiosis, a prokaryote that
got consumed so completely by its symbiotic
relationship inside another organism that it has
become an organelle. The process of endosymbiosis
is complete when the endosymbiont has lost most
of its genes or given them over to its host.
And that endosymbiotic history complicates our
human desire to distinguish between an organelle
and an organism. But fortunately,
we do have molecular tools that
allow us to investigate further.
This diatom, Epithemia gibba, has had at
least two distinct things noted about it:
one is its unusual capacity to convert extremely
stable but biologically useless diatomic nitrogen
into actually useful nitrogen compounds, we call
this “nitrogen fixing”. And the other thing that
people have noted about it is the round bits
that appear like beady bubbles inside of it.
When scientists looked closer, they found that the
round bodies had a double membrane around them,
suggesting that they might be another
organism living inside the diatom.
So they spun the diatoms and treated them with
chemicals to extract these mystery parts and
study the genes inside them, ultimately finding
that the diatom was occupied by cyanobacteria.
These cyanobacteria, it turns out, are responsible
for the diatom’s ability to fix nitrogen. But
when it comes to the question of organelle versus
organism, well this cyanobacteria is kind of both.
It doesn’t appear to perform photosynthesis
in the diatom, its main function is to fix
nitrogen. But to enter into that relationship
with its host, the cyanobacteria had to change
its own nitrogen-fixation schedule to match
the diatom’s daily photosynthetic activities.
The extent of the cyanobacteria’s adaptation to
its host and the fact that it is passed on from
generation to generation of diatom suggests
that while those cyanobacteria might still
be their own selves, they may be on their way
to becoming an organelle, fully endosymbiosed
into a piece of Epithelia gibba.
And other mysteries remain,
even when they seem initially clear-cut.
This Loxodes rostrum is a rare find for us,
but it is also quite distinctive because it bears
not one, but two different types of algae in it.
And now, that might seem like yet another
version of the Paramecium bursaria and
Chlorella relationship we saw earlier. We
have a large ciliate occupied by algae,
combining their respective bodies and machinery to
supply different forms of nutrition to each other
that neither would get on its own. There’s
nothing weird about this, right? Nothing
startling, nothing extraordinarily strange.
Except that Loxodes rostrum are also full of
pigments to avoid light because they don’t like
light. They practically melt when they’re exposed
to light. And that’s a problem for algae because
light is kind of part of their thing. Like,
it’s an important part of photosynthesis.
So how do they survive together?
Why are they doing this? We don’t know.
There must have been some kind of compromise.
The nature of that compromise remains unknown
to us. Maybe they’re just like that couple who
seem deeply incompatible, and yet somehow,
they need each other and they make it work.
At least, that’s how it looks from
the outside. But in the future,
generations of Loxodes from now, maybe
this relationship will look different.
And perhaps, like every other
relationship, it will evolve,
helping both organisms confront new challenges
that the world will inevitably throw at them.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Fabulous
for sponsoring this episode.
Every year most people set new-year's
resolutions but around 80% of those
will get abandoned in just the first 2 months.
The best way to succeed with your resolutions
is to transform them into tiny habits
and stick to them thanks to the Fabulous app.
Developed by behavioral scientists at Duke
University, Fabulous has guided journeys
for common resolutions like exercising more,
improving your sleep, and eating healthier.
It’s the #1 self care and habit forming app
in the app store with over 20 million users,
and it can help you whether you’re
looking for ways to stay focused at work
or you just need a reminder to take a break
once in a while to stretch and drink some water
There’s no shortcut to changing habits. With
your resolution this year, consider a proven,
affordable, sustainable, long-term
approach to changing your life,
one that builds on your successes.
The app is 100% personalized to your goals and
you can start building your ideal daily routine
today! And the first 100 people who click
on the link in the description will get
25% off a Fabulous subscription.
You want to talk about a symbiotic relationship?
How about the one that we have with the people
whose names are on the screen right now. They
are our Patreon patrons. They want there to be
good, educational, interesting, chill,
microscope content on the internet.
And we want to make it, but we need their support.
And so, that relationship has come together,
and what is the result? This video and
all of the other videos on this channel.
If you want to be one of these people
who make it possible for us to do this
and also get access to some pretty cool perks,
you can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And it you want to see more from us,
I bet you, I bet you can find a
subscribe button somewhere nearby.